[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
wir kommen auf dem kulturplatz ja wir
leben im zeitalter der selbstdarstellung
und überlegen jeden tag aufs neue wie
viel wir von uns selbst preisgeben
wollen
meine maxime ich zeige mein gesicht
nicht aber das meiner kinder
umso mehr ist mir dieser bildband
aufgefallen es ist das intime porträt
einer mutter die fotografie goalie
marschall hat während 25 jahren das
heranwachsen ihrer söhne mit der kamera
begleitet was das bedeutet darüber
spreche ich jetzt mit mutter und sohn
[Musik]
carolin mersch all das ist es unser
können das land zieht reaktor sita
realisiert hat ihre zürcher wohnung
kanadier fotosessions medien müssen
stattgefunden der rhythmus ist sie
einmal im monat gibt es foto- shooting
genau das nicht irgendwann also ganz am
anfang entschieden denkt also einfach
rein aus dem buch das ich kenne
zum probieren so der richtige rhythmus
verfangen habe wo das ganze dokumentiert
nur ziel und nicht wenig dass man die
entwicklung schönen mädchen über und
ganz am anfang vor ihrem buch stadt der
buch im buch war langsam wächst ist dass
da eigentlich die intention sieht es mit
festhalten war so sein muss
ja klar also einfach die information
dass also ich bin schwanger was mache
ich musste als fotograf hin und es ist
total abstrakt am anfang wie wie wie
soll ich wo soll ihrer auffangen oder
und dann gibt es wirklich nötig sei und
ja nicht einfach angefangen und denkt
kauft irgendwann geht es hin wo sind sie
denn vor augen hatte vorausgegangen dass
das land sieht reaktiviert gut davon
ausgegangen
dabei hofft natürlich dass es lang geht
ohne als wirkliche eisriesen frage sexy
wie überhaupt was passiert oder
[Musik]
achtzehnter februar 1996 der kleine
berlin hat seinen ersten auftritt vor
der kamera
einmal im monat fotografiert carolina
soll ihr wunder
zweieinhalb jahre später ist das zweite
wunder dass die monatlichen fotosessions
gehen weiter aus dem wunsch die freuden
des mutter werden es festzuhalten
entsteht ein kunstprojekt die fotografen
inszeniert ihre söhne arbeitet mit
accessoires und schreibt ihnen bewusst
rollen zu je älter die jungs werden umso
mehr bringen sie sich dabei auch selbst
mit ein
[Musik]
doch dann haben die beiden genug von den
allmonatlichen inszenierungen als merlin
18 wird ist schluss
trotzdem möchten die söhne das langzeit
kunstprojekt ihrer mutter nicht
sabotieren
sie entscheiden sich ab dafür ein
schlichtes porträt shooting drei bis
viermal im jahr die meisten fotos
entstehen bei carolina soll im
wohnzimmer immer mit dabei
die analoge hasselblad kamera im 6 x 6
format mit schwarz weiß film die söhne
verändern sich über die jahre die
bildqualität bleibt dieselbe
dadurch wirken die fotos zeitlos
das buch from iwo ist mehr als ein
privates fotoalbum unweigerlich denkt
man beim betrachten an die eigene
biografie die etappen der eigenen
kindheit und jugend
die bilder werfen aber auch die frage
nach dem recht des kindes auf das eigene
bild auf und vereinzelte stimmen
empfinden die nackte haut als
grenzwertig früchte bereit zu
konsumieren
in manchen fotos liefert carolina soll
bewusst mehrere deutungen ebenen 19
april 2020 das letzte bild des projekts
ein vierteljahrhundert berlin und basel
sind im buch festgehalten
die fotografischen runde wohl im
wohnzimmer gehen aber weiter wie ist das
csu wachse mit so viel wilder wo man so
intim porträtiert wird und jetzt kann
das jeder der sie in lauter gepostet
will für fotografie
wo ist eigentlich schon recht lang im
öffentlichen raum standen natürlich
jetzt mehr über das buch direkt über
persönliche probleme im rampenlicht
stehe oder das gesetz werden oder was
weiß ich nicht immer haben lust karriere
auf die fotoshootings hat das magath
team wird alles ganz doch jetzt mal in
der tasche nach acs vor
ja das ist sich zitate sie an ihre
kinder und 20 minuten im monat sie
machen und dass moussavi machen das nach
roche oder was weiß er was hat das land
sie brachten mit ihrer beziehung macht
mit ihrer mutter sohn beziehung
die fotografien bis jetzt nicht sie sind
natürlich ein protest ja ja was sagen
sie caroline zum vorwurf dass sie für
ihre grundschulkinder instrumentalisiert
hat ja jetzt rangliste mental ihren wenn
es hinten und weltoffen sie kann man
sowieso das bild nicht machen also es
gab gar nicht mit 30 oder es hat nicht
sagen warum ich jetzt oder sie stets
kaiser geld oder er meint aber ich mache
das kind weg geebnet mit und missbrauch
ja das ist natürlich ein großes thema
oder mit eigenen bild und aber ich meine
es gibt reis baby hinter wirklich so
schlecht stelle das ist für mich denke
ich problematisch können sie was haben
die denn titel zum thema nacktheit die
ganze familie zeigt ja auch immer wieder
naja also als ich natürlich man muss
sich vor 25 jahren und nacktheit ist vor
allem vor hinter und anderer licht
gestanden als fit + ich bin natürlich
vor allem auch mutter und mutter und und
sich auch aus der überlegung ist los
sport das spielt natürlich eine rolle
wenn die kleider und so das sind
merkmale von einer bestimmten zeit aber
am anfang finde ich das baby ist das
baby es ist ja der ältere bruder berlin
ist der einst ausgesehen die mantra muss
sich dank der moment von dem buch oder
geboren wird ist kein zufälliger moment
das hat an die von darabos fauser
caroline absolut das ist für mich auch
ein schöner abschluss und wie quasi zwar
noch kreiseigenen buch von mir mit 70
aber es ist auch wir aber es ist dagegen
wie
ja wie es ist geschenkt um ihnen ganz
herzlicher dank dawal in brazil dass
mehr davon
[Musik]
jetzt sind wir hier in der zürcher badi
tiefenbrunnen auch ein ort wo man sich
gerne präsentiert
[Musik]
vielseitiges bild zu rücken weiß sich
auch der schauspieler sänger und
regisseur ihren mcgregor ob shakespeare
auf der bühne star wars im owl oder aber
aus sänger im film moulin rouge der
schotte kann es heute weder 50
congratulations ein guter grund für uns
seinen werdegang etwas genauer zu
beleuchten
[Musik]
sag ja zum leben sagt herzlichen job
sagt ja zur familie sagt ja zu einem
pervers großen fernseher waschmaschinen
autos cd playern und elektrischen
dosenöffner mark trend weg von seinen
raub opfern aber vor allem weg von sich
selber dem konsum im sinn des bürgertums
ziethe den heroinkonsum vor
[Musik]
ich habe zum jahr sagen nein gesagt ich
hab so was anderem jahr gesagt
und der grund dafür
es gibt keinen grund dafür wer braucht
gründe wenn er heroin hat trainspotting
spielt in edinburgh zu einer zeit als
europa und die schweiz gerade von einer
heroin welle überschwemmt werden
regisseur danny boyle wurde damals
vorgeworfen drogenkonsum im film zu
verherrlichen
[Musik]
trinks
zu unrecht der film zeigt brutal und
schonungslos wohin sucht führen kann
ich glaube erlassen hatte schon den
ganzen tag lang geschrieben aber ich
hatte es vorher irgendwie nicht richtig
registriert kann auch sein dass sie
schon eine ganze woche geschrieben hatte
[Musik]
nichts hätte weiter weg von der wahrheit
sagen können trainspotting brennt sich
ein genauso wie ewan mcgregors starke
darstellen eines verzweifelten selbst
betrügers wie die filmzeitung variety
anerkennt schäbig brutal und tipp
trainspotting ist das clockwork orange
der 90er jahre
die darsteller sind auf allen ebenen
grandios insbesondere mcgregor als
sympathischer marke trainspotting mit
seinem ikonischen soundtrack wird zum
durchbruch für den damals 25-jährigen
ewan mcgregor musik hatte der
schauspieler damals längst im blut als
ausgebildeter gitarrist und schlagzeuger
vor allem aber als sänger
[Musik]
in velvet goldmann gibt mcgregor zwei
jahre nach trainspotting den rockstar
court wild verwechslungsgefahr mit kult
rocker kurt cobain erwünscht
eine komplett andere gemütslage schlägt
er im musical moulin rouge mit co star
nicole kidman an vier der songs im film
hat mit reagan selbst geschrieben
[Musik]
als linie den singenden kerzenständer in
beauty and the beast hat sich der
schotte mcgregor sogar einen
französischen akzent zugelegt
mcgregor ist einer der vielseitigsten
schauspieler unserer zeit lang liebhaber
fantast in big fish oder der legendäre
star wars jedi ritter obi wan kenobi für
keine einzige seiner kinorollen hat er
bisher einen großen film kreis erhalten
[Musik]
nun film preise allein machen noch keine
guten schauspieler ewan mcgregor dürfte
sich in ein paar jahren ohnehin für die
ehrenpreise für sein vielfältiges
lebenswerk empfehlen
und bis dahin einfach weiter singen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in szene setzen wollen sie auch die
newcomer in der schweizer musikbranche
zwar beim prestigeträchtigen festival
for music dort startete schon manche
karriere so etwa die von steff la cheffe
nun hat sich der aktuelle jahrgang der
jury gestellt und das fand corona
bedingt unter ganz speziellen regeln
statt
so liegt am lg mini ist sie aller demo
tape klinik in four music präsentiert
sich dieses mal an drei tagen als
komplett digitales festival auch die
demotape clinic der nachwuchswettbewerb
des migros kulturprozent ließ sich als
stream verfolgen
in den kategorien rock/pop lyrics und
beats und elektronik brutale die drei
jurymitglieder im zürcher schiffbau über
die eingesandten songs aus den mehreren
hundert songs hat es auch die basler
band mal unter die besten 60 geschafft
[Musik]
das trio hat bereits ein erstes album
aufgenommen das herzstück von unserem
album der klinik ist doch dass es nur
einmal im jahr stattfindet und durch
dass es die größe etwas was hat eine
wurde wirkte ja und coole fuchsberger
events es gibt
[Musik]
nachdem die drei blatt eingereicht haben
werden sie nun beim livestream
zugeschaltet und erfahren wie ihr demo
tape bei der jury ankommt
und da sind sie schon bei uns im stream
hallo zusammen wunderbar seid ihr hier
wir haben feedback verdi für euch eine
schöne produktion die stimme ist super
hier experimentiert produktion mega cool
für mich ist beim song fehlt mir der
refrain ein bisschen ich würde auch wenn
man wieder spielen kann unbedingt die
schweiz abklappern weil ich kann mir
ganz viele lokale vorstellen und das
ganz toll reinpassen würde haye lumi
danke wir hier viel glück weiterhin und
wir machen jetzt weiter mit little falls
sie waren sehr ernst und direkt das
gefällt mir wenn ich jetzt rennt vor ort
es ist die 23 der ausgabe dieses talent
wettbewerbs selbst für erfahrene
festivalmacher ihnen in dieser form
anspruchsvoll fuß setzte jetzt der
pandemie sind sehr schwierig sie die
datei klinik bootsführer jury muss
anhand seiner moderation wo muss die
stanze und die künstlerinnen und
künstler trend vor ort sie und ich
glaube es ist trotz denken stück weit
verstanden intimität herstellen und zu
mir gesagt
trotz allem seelisch news corp
überzeugt haben viele aber wer sind nun
die besten
[Applaus]
die zürcherinnen bad bears gewinnen
sowohl in ihrer kategorie rock als auch
den hauptpreis das demo tape oder her
und so mit 5000 franken
keine auszeichnung für die basler band
dennoch hat sich die teilnahme für miami
gelobt denn er hat meine plattform
blickwinkel ist es immer so viel sport
treibt und es stört mich so eine riesige
wagen die wettbewerber stück oder
konzert oder so dann hat wie es dazu kam
war und das den neuen beruf oder
raubüberfälle öffnen einer tür hat sich
für maloney schon geöffnet ihr debüt
album blood erscheint bald bei einem
schweizer vertrieb
[Musik]
das war unsere sendung zur frage wie wir
das bild von uns selbst regieren und
gestalten der nächste woche da machen
wir eine reise in die jüngere
vergangenheit nämlich in die zeit von
schul fez von mixtapes und vom dia show
in meiner jugend vielleicht auch in ihre
und jetzt gleich folgt die serie fossey
würden hier auf sf1 eine frohe
osterwoche
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
fristlos